seine schwester herzlich willkommen zu
meinem heutigen video leute wir spielen
einfach mal wieder eine entspannte runde
foto roulette mit sandra und day
es wurde nicht gekocht falls ihr sehen
wollt mich das kochen soll die heute
leider kompletträder platz kommt
trotzdem zu den lustig foto red habe ich
schon ein einziges mal aufgenommen ich
glaube das ist gar nicht so bekannt in
nicht youtube kreisen denn sie spielen
das immer häufiger also mit luca und so
auch nicht bei der party von jan vom
gewitter und oftmals auch gespielt es
ist sehr lustig also funktioniert so wie
er drei geben der applord zugriff auf
unsere fotos auf alle fotos beim letzten
mal der skandal
egal wie wenig darüber und es wird uns
dreien gleichzeitig ein foto angezeigt
wir müssen raten von wem es kommt kein
würde sagen es ist er relativ
selbsterklärend deshalb erstelle ich
immer ein gamepro
es geht schon hatte ich doch ist man
erkennt halt alles immer weiter dass ich
das bin
das land stelle aber es geht auch um
geschwindigkeit naja gutes gespräch ja
das war die runde startet jetzt
passieren dabei folge sogar sagen
erklärte foto sehen die fotos damit sich
der präsident sie sind
[Musik]
das ist auch machen
also packt besser ist es okay wer treibt
ein steak hat das nein
das passt das ist übrigens mal war obama
auf die bestimmung wieder aufgesetzt
awlaki bewegen
das übrig so laurin schott aus meiner
youtube app die gezeigt hat wie viel ihr
zuschaute
das können wir beide seiten ja aber ich
habe die post noch instagram ist eine
schande dass waren die sachen die dave
damals für luca versorgen gesorgt hatte
oh mein gott
nein ich wollte es ihm bald stehen
wahrscheinlich sie beginnt also der
linken so alex freundin rechts war so
gewollt ist okay alter geht das schnell
muss das ist 100 prozent richtig los und
ich habe gott das kann auch noch das ist
so wahlleiter ihren ungeschnitten videos
nimmt die kamera auseinander
die erste runde geht nichts zu sehen
ich habe ich denke langes schrieb dass
sechs bilder in folge richtig geraten
es geht halt echt krank schnell ok stark
wie direkt in die nächste runde
mal stand er gerade steht damit nicht
abonniert ist doch cool du bist nicht
der motor und antrieb ist dass seine
schwester ich dachte dass gemeinschaft
hier hat das war in münchen war das
diese gruppe von uns geschickt und wir
beide haben können what the [ __ ]
breiding bei angeblichen gehabt außerdem
spricht man gesichert ich muss mal
starten aber ganz schnell
oh ja ok asien und rollerfahren beste
alter kulow
wer sich wer die kaufen sich kontron /
gerade ihre kleider gericht aber
gefährlicher macht einmal gefastet hat
hier jede und jeder mag schwester weiß
auch nicht wann welche die ganze zeit so
gut jetzt habt ihr ja ja
lässt sich das zwar es war von mir
erwarten das kann nur da sind ja nicht
gesagt dass kann nur jetzt glaube ich
nicht gewählt auch so wichtig genommen
okay das ist doch eine rolle spielen bei
mir ist egal ob werbung bis 110 sofort
wieder da wer dafür runde starten
diesmal das bin ich dass dies ein fehler
dass wir heute im wald gepennt haben ja
okay das war die zeit als ich mit jakob
wie sonst durch sein kann dass die
kleinen ist mit dieser mutter ausbildung
ausbildung davon drehen
man kann da nichts leben nachricht man
kommt nur verlieren und ein
hochattraktives kotow und skifahren
damit aus der challenge ist wirklich so
schwer
du hast echt komplett nur selbst raus
was kommt dazu dieses mutter sehen wieso
immer unterdrückt wird und ein 12
[Applaus]
dafür ist die komplette familie herkommt
xii
wenn ich jedoch ein wohin gehören zehn
oder den abwehrmann mit der
kartoffelernte schleppt das von
undercover geholt hat richtig spass auf
den perfekt der flüge ist es war mein
konto um 11 uhr los mit zwei punkten
gewonnen
210 sondern häufig zu übernehmen ich
hätte doch alles richtig gerade aber du
bist nicht schmecken
es geht doch auch stimmig schnelligkeit
und gehören dort 14 das trinken sie
einfach sagt mir das tsg team
schnelligkeit
aber es geht auch um geschwindigkeit und
eine runde gegner kommen wir zur alles
entscheidenden runde es geht darum wer
gewonnen hat ist egal ob du 20 10
das macht nicht so dass parteien erfolg
weiter bis sie gut auch amsterdam das
ganze ja da missbraucht ich habe mir
sagt schulte streichen des briten haye
kommen
machst du da schreibst und ihr manager
ist echt sei nur taktik ganz maryland
schwester
ja ich hab manchmal weiter so mal hier
mit fotos von lama bei seiner politik
ihrer oberen gesichtshälfte bei date
irgendwas anderes meinen aber das hat
nicht jeder gemacht so ein foto oder
hast du so abhängig so geschickt
bekommen ich habe nie so leere regale
gesehen ich schon das könnte mir da von
uns sein wird aber ich sag mal du führst
kaum weißt du bescheid schnell sein muss
in dieser runde schon einmal da ist
jetzt ein anderes wesen immer wieder
station dann erkennt und kühle sommer
und damit du bist die siegerin des
heutigen tages ja dann gehört es geht um
alles es hat spaß gemacht falls ihr euch
übrigens die ganze zeit gefragt habe wo
sind die ihr dave und ich haben sich
beruhigt und das reicht mir ein dass es
nicht von uns das ist von den promis
wird sehr wild was in der nächsten zeit
aber ich zukommt sondern vielen dank
dass du dabei warst gedanke nicht alles
noch mal selbst das war sehr gut